aucun ne nous connaissait vraiment les
autres on est tous des ratés mais
bizarrement on était tous au même
endroit au même moment quand billy a
trouvé ces pièces
regardez aubry les gars moi j'suis bleus
et moi noir quoi si c'est vrai nom des
capteurs
tu te sens bizarre on est fort
incroyablement fins
leur réponse à ce qui vous arrive se
trouve ici
tous les cinq
vous êtes les power rangers
vous venez de dire qu'on était des power
rangers signe blague ou quoi on parle à
un mur je m'attendais à mieux que vous
[Musique]
tu t'es où hier soir avec quatre potes
on a trouvé un vaisseau spatial enfouis
sous terre
je crois que j'ai des super pouvoirs
coût 10 dans ce bocal les power rangers
était une armée de guerriers devait
devenir ces guerriers
c'est qu'un hologramme comme dans un jeu
vidéo dont le genre hologramme icône
fort c'est par un jeu vidéo
non mais
vous êtes né pour ça
j'ai tout détruire
c'est le mal incarné
du coup on fait comment pour l'arrêter
c'est l'heure de la transformation et bd
et les barrières
ça fait un paquet d'or
c'est votre destin
encore
votre heure est venue
à
[Musique]